[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de france 24 y para este primer capítulo
hemos venido a la región de dordoña en
el sudoeste de este país donde se
encuentra el famoso castillo de mil
hombres
[Música]
este edificio renacentista fue entre
1937 y 1969 la casa de la primera gran
vedette negra de fama internacional
josephine baker ella entrará
simbólicamente al panteón francés el
próximo 30 de noviembre en esta selecta
necrópolis descansan ya cinco mujeres y
75 hombres vengan con nosotros a conocer
la morada donde vivió con su tribu
arcoiris
50 de sus 68 años de vida josephine
baker los pasó en francia y la mayor
parte vivió en este castillo de alquiler
primero y luego como su dueña
cuando josephine llego al castillo de
milán en 1937 es verdaderamente el
inicio de su carrera ella llega a parís
en 1925 en 1930 llega a lyf oliver ríe y
usa el cinturón de bananas se hace
conocida saca una línea de cosméticos
todos los diseñadores quieren tenerla
como imagen de marca en los años 30 a
ellas ya tenía fama y descubre este
castillo que es como el de cenicienta y
se enamora de él y desde 1947 es decir
después de la guerra tiene suficiente
dinero como para comprarlo los actuales
propietarios de mi la onda ha levantado
un pequeño museo en homenaje al artista
que evidentemente exhibe los vestidos
usados en 54 años de carrera
aquí tenemos el cinturón de bananas que
usó josephine desde 1930 cuando se
presentaba en la fe librar rey cocido
con hilos de oro y aquí vemos que se
trata de un círculo que rodea las
caderas
pero allí queda la parte frívola de la
estadounidense el castillo quiere
mostrar sobre todo su lado humano cómo
se vino a dordoña con la idea de formar
su villa de la fraternidad universal
donde funcionaba un parque de
atracciones y hasta un teatro donde ella
actuaba josephine adopto 12 niños de
distintos lugares del mundo su tribu
arcoiris ella la mejor madre que sin
embargo no pudo tener hijos propios
josephine quería crear esta ciudad de la
fraternidad y quería probarle al mundo
entero que niños de orígenes y
religiones distintas podrían vivir
juntos en paz y alegría para ella había
sólo una raza y era la raza humana
entonces comenzó a adoptar poco a poco
desde los años 50 primero en japón y
luego cada vez que hacía una gira atraía
a un niño por decirlo así su papel
crucial en la resistencia a la ocupación
así también tiene un lugar importante
allí está la legión de honor la medalla
de la resistencia o la cruz de guerra
que obtuvo como reconocimiento por su
labor de espía
no está en cambio la cruz de los genes
que le entregó el general de gaulle pues
ella la remató en beneficio de la
resistencia
qué va
conoció al capitán apte del
contraespionaje que la integró en la red
de resistentes se fue de gira a varios
países y allí recuperó informaciones que
escondía en sus partituras con tinta
invisible gracias a su celebridad nadie
se atrevía a regresar la iba también a
cenas solemnes y conoció a gente muy
importante cuando vino el castillo en
los años 40 ayudó a escondiendo armas y
resistentes no le daba miedo ella decía
parís me dio su corazón es normal que yo
le dé el mío incluso se hizo denunciar
no todo era fácil pero ella decía hay
una danza que yo no bailo y es la guerra
la cocina del castillo fue el último
sitio que abandonó el artista antes de
ser expulsada de mi londres debido a sus
deudas
se atrincheró y resistió como ya lo
había hecho otras muchas veces sentada
en la puerta lejos del glamour de antaño
dejar el castillo y todo lo que allí
creo fue un duro golpe para el
estadounidense que falleció seis años
después de un derrame cerebral cuando
presentaba su espectáculo biográfico
[Música]
y para conocer más sobre josephine baker
y el castillo de milán 2 nos encontramos
con una de las fanáticas más importante
del artista que es el inglés alex preddy
que es la propietaria de este dato
gracias a él y por acompañarnos en
france 24 gracias por venir el 2011
primero que nada cómo es que tú que
naciste un año después del fallecimiento
de josephine baker conoces tanto de la
artista
mis padres conocieron a josephine baker
pero yo no nunca he conocido a sus hijos
pero desde muy pequeña es que nací en
shah alam muy cerca de aquí y mis padres
me han hablado muchas veces de ella es
una gran gran personalidad
y cuéntanos cómo es que josephine viene
a vivir a francia porque sale de los
eeuu porque tiene en una época cuando
ella tiene 18 años le gustaba mucho
bailar y también disfrutar de la vida y
una vez será en nueva york' y conoció a
una persona importante en francia que
querían descubrir artistas
como bailadoras y músicos
y ella dijo si quiero ir en francia a
bailar por la famosa revista negra una
revista que hablaba de los negros pero
es era una manera para los negros de
también de burlarse de los blancos y del
colonialismo es verdad que ella había
sufrido en carne propia en eeuu la
discriminación mientras trabajaba como
empleada doméstica no en una casa si es
que desde muy joven su madre
le obliga a trabajar en las familias de
blancos y era para ella un momento muy
difícil a vivir
y cuando se casó por primera vez a sus
13 años para ella es una manera de
liberarse de una oprimida de bueno es
una una chica que le gusta la libertad y
que no quiere un marido todos los días y
hacer la limpieza de la casa llega a
parís como tú decías participa en la
revista de negros es verdad que aquí no
había quizás la discriminación racial
que había en eeuu pero sí no es cierto
se trataba las personas negras o de
razas exóticas justamente como eso como
raro pero ella tuvo una
inteligencia y supo sacar provecho de
esa situación no lo más conocido es la
el baile con la cintura con el cinturón
de bananas
para ella es una manera una manera de
vivir otra cosa y francia es un país de
libertad cuando ella va en la
en la estación de tren que llegó a parís
esque
va a encontrar personas blancas que
dicen hola buenos días señora y para
ella que era negra no ha visto nunca eso
en américa y luego viene su compromiso
lo cierto con francia con la resistencia
cómo es que pasa eso de los cabarets y
de la música a algo tan distinto cuando
los alemanes llegaron a en parís es el
momento en el que ellos decían no quiere
cantar por los alemanes por eso se fue
el limón aquí porque esta propiedad va a
alquilarla a partir del año 38 y es en
este momento particular en el que
estamos en el año 40 va a escuchar a la
general de gaulle el 18 de junio
y ella comprende que tiene que trabajar
por la francia libre es muy importante
para ella y quiere luchar hasta el final
hasta la liberación de francia angelique
y en bueno era una mujer que nos damos
cuenta era muy valiente no le tenía
miedo a nada es quizás lo que más le
costó en su vida fue el rechazo de su
país muchas veces viajó a eeuu pensaban
que le iban a recibir con las puertas
abiertas y seguía sufriendo la
discriminación racial pero al final
quizás su logro más grande ya dijo el
día más importante de mi vida cuando
participó en la marcha en washington por
los derechos civiles si es este día para
ella era estupendo porque
va a hablar frente a muchos amigos
negros a defender los derechos cívicos
para ella es lo más importante en su
vida es eso es dar una importancia o un
bienestar a las personas negras y
entonces es eso justamente y desde tu
punto de vista cuáles son los méritos
que hacen que ellos se sienten que sea
la sexta mujer en entrar al panteón
francés
para mí es un poco lo que dije lo que
dije antes es decir el compromiso
durante la guerra pienso que el
presidente marco ha elegido también
para eso porque mostrar que un
persona que no era francesa en sus
originales puede dar su vida a nuestro
país y es lo que hemos aprendido este
día maravilloso que hemos pasado en el
llanto de mi auto y muchas gracias ángel
y muchas gracias a ti
[Música]
y ellos
un hombre
y
[Música]
nunca
cuando salió definitivamente el trato de
milán de josephine baker fue vivir a
mónaco donde su amiga la actriz
estadounidense grace kelly le prestó un
departamento de hecho se encuentra allí
enterrada junto a su último marido sin
embargo sus hijos no han querido mover
los restos y por lo mismo aquí en el
panteón habrá simplemente una placa
conmemorativa
no lejos del panteón aquí en la corte de
justicia de parís sigue el proceso por
los atentados del 13 de noviembre en
francia en estos días hemos escuchado
los testimonios de los rescatados de la
sala de conciertos bataclán pero también
de los familiares de las personas que
allí fallecieron nosotros conversamos
con lancé una chilena que ha previsto
quedarse nueve meses en parís para
seguir este proceso ella perdiendo el
bataclán a su hijo luis felipe es
importante para mí porque se lo debo a
mi hijo y además que quiero saber quiero
respuestas quiero saber por qué le han
quitado la vida a mi hijo que no ya mil
es decir a cientos de personas inocentes
y creo que en este proceso se va a
dilucidar y bueno sobre muchas cosas que
hasta el minuto no
no sé
el comienzo yo no sabía que esta sala de
cambio estar presente y ver lo fue
impresionante por porque sentí mucha
rabia
de melo también para el vivo
y
haciendo declaraciones
y tan desafiante que me parece increíble
es
bueno yo creo que durante todo el
proceso me tendré que acostumbrar a este
tipo de situaciones no sé si soportar
esto todos los días porque esto fuerte
esto es
es como
revivir parte de todo esto fan somos
muchos en realidad somos muchos las
familiares de las víctimas y estamos
creo que todos presentes porque yo creo
que todos queremos lo mismo que se haga
justicia y así terminamos este capítulo
de francia en foco gracias por su
compañía siguen ustedes con la
programación habitual de france 24 y
hasta la próxima
[Música]